[Musica]
d
chi si è mai sentito invisibile a scuola
quando facevo il liceo c'era questo
ragazzo nella mia classe era un tipo un
po introverso non
eccellente negli studi ma senz'altro un
grande lettore è un giorno il club se
stava leggendo uno dei suoi libri senza
fare attenzione come sempre è
l'insegnante l'ha affermato la lezione e
gli ha detto tu finirai a inscatolare le
merendine
in fabbrica
mi ricordo la sua espressione era come
se l'avessero pugnalato ecco in quel
momento il filo che lo teneva a malapena
aggrappato all'educazione
spezzato
da quel giorno quel ragazzo era come un
fantasma in classe presente ma
invisibile
un altro uno dei tanti caduto nelle
crepe del sistema
e come potrebbe essere altrimenti quando
la scuola italiana versa in condizioni
tanto drammatiche
ho incontrato alunni insegnanti e
presidi in tutto il paese da nord a sud
dalle isole alla penisola e ovunque la
percezione l'acqua quasi unanime la
scuola italiana in crisi
al contempo però io penso che questa
percezione sia falsata
si crede spesso che la crisi della
scuola italiana sia relativa
infrastrutturale di finanziamenti e lo è
anche ma è soprattutto una crisi
culturale spesso sentito il paragone tra
le scuole italiane e le scuole del sud
globale
il paragone tra le nostre aule fredde e
le loro di lamiera poi i nostri
programmi e loro ecco questo è un
paragone crisi stereotipato così abusato
che io penso che al giorno d'oggi non
abbia ragione di esistere ma soprattutto
è un paragone che è atto a banalizzare
la crisi della scuola italiana
la verità è che la nostra crisi e
subdola meno evidente delle pareti di
lamiera
anni crivellato dai proiettili
è una crisi la nostra di contenuto non
di contenitore in italia noi sappiamo
cosa si impara ma non perché ed è per
questo che i nostri ragazzi sentono
invisibili e i nostri adulti impreparati
al mondo
perché la nostra scuola è una scuola che
non ascolta
la nostra non è una semplice crisi è
un'emergenza
non ci credi
questi sono i dati ufficiali abbandono
scolastico
uno su sette dai nostri ragazzi non
arriva al diploma è uno dei tassi di
dispersione più alti in europa
competenze matematiche linguistica e una
volta raggiunto il diploma il 50 per
cento dei nostri studenti non le ottiene
livello di soddisfazione degli
insegnanti degli alunni ma anche dei
genitori sotto al 50 per cento
siamo i primi al mondo per il livello di
ansia degli studenti
formazione docenti il 75 per cento dei
nostri insegnanti non fa corsi di
potenziamento dopo l'abilitazione
e per finire
investimenti nella scuola
noi siamo il 100 ventunesimi al mondo
questi numeri rappresentano solo art
dell'emergenza quella formale
purtroppo c'è molto altro l'emergenza
nella scuola italiana è soprattutto
umana perché come può lo studente
sentirsi visti in un sistema scolastico
che si ripresenta tale e quale con
classi della stessa dimensione stessa
forma stessi colori da ormai
sessant'anni
com'è possibile che gli studenti ci
sembrano visti se gli insegnanti vengono
assegnati rimossi fatti rotolare di
continuo senza un vero piano a lungo
termine come possono i docenti imparare
a conoscere gli studenti ai loro bisogni
e come possono gli studenti anche solo
chiedere di essere visti se su 168 ore
in una settimana
vengono invitati a scuola solo per 25
ecco è impossibile che un insegnante
diventi un punto di riferimento per la
vita in classi sempre sovraffollate
questo scollamento tra il cosa e perché
si sostanzia anche nei programmi che per
esempio in storia finiscono appena dopo
la seconda guerra mondiale senza mai di
collegarsi al presente e quindi bimbi
se non solo il domani anche l'oggi dei
nostri studenti non viene rappresentato
nei percorsi di studio come fanno loro
stesse a sentirsi visti il quale dunque
il risultato di tutto questo
il risultato è una scuola che smette di
essere scuola e diventa catena di
montaggio un luogo di solo cosa e niente
perché un luogo freddo brutto in cui li
l'individualità è scoraggiata
l'insegnante abbandonato a se stesso la
creatività messa a tacere
l'ambizione malvista l'umanità
dell'apprendimento lasciata in sospeso
un luogo in cui scegliere e scegliere
bene semplicemente non fa parte del
programma e non trovi quindi che sia
ironico come quell'insegnante abbia
prospettato al mio compagno di finire a
inscatolare merendine quando verrà lei
stessa farlo in scatola le nozioni e
trasmetterle senza un vero perché
come in fabbrica
lo so è uno scenario angosciante quello
che descrivo ma se lo faccio perché
credo e con me tanti altri che le
urgenza sia massima che ne vada dal
futuro delle nuove generazioni e anche
del nostro
soprattutto penso che il primo passo per
risolvere qualsiasi problema sia quello
di ammetterlo e sono qui oggi per
proporre una soluzione un po inusuale di
solito si guarda sempre a paesi più
forti nell'istruzione come la finlandia
danimarca svezia per cercare i rimedi
stavolta ti invito a guardare nella
direzione opposta
negli ultimi anni mi sono dedicato alla
direzione di un'organizzazione che si
occupa di aprire scuole di livello
internazionale nei contesti
più svantaggiati dal globo
attraverso l'esperienza accumulata sul
campo sentiamo di avere sviluppato
quattro soluzioni quattro pilastri
fondamentali della scuola di domani
e questi sono
numero uno la scuola e casa
si dice che la bellezza salverà il mondo
e in italia siamo degli specialisti in
questo molto delle nostre scuole e
sorgono i palazzi storici edifici
bellissimi ma poco valorizzati sappiamo
che lo spazio alla forza di educare
tanto quanto una lezione e apprendere in
uno spazio bello di cui diventare
proprietari responsabili e prendersi
cura è di per sé giove una forma di
educazione
a concretizzare
ho preso di vecchio liceo e l'ho
trasformato secondo il nostro modello
educativo
materiali caldi e domestici confort cate
caratterizzazione degli spazi
versatilità della didattica serenità
calma concentrazione usare la luce per
disegnare gli ambienti e prima che tu
possa obiettare fermo subito ogni ma
economico
il corso di questa ristrutturazione è
solo una frazione del budget annuale di
una scuola
numero due
lo studente al centro nella scuola di
domani tutti si chiamano per nome
proprio questi alle elementari come le
superiori
questo permette la creazione di rapporti
autentici che trascendano ruolo e titolo
e mettano in primo piano la persona con
la sua unicità
dividere studenti per competenze non
perita in modo che nessuno senta mai
inadeguato nel percorso di studi e
soprattutto tutto lo studente sceglie le
materie che comporranno il suo anno
scolastico insieme all'insegnante fissa
i suoi obiettivi in base alle proprie
attitudini e capacità individuali punto
terzo
pensiero globale
è necessario inizia a esplorare il
perché delle cose non solo il cosa il
come il quando e il dove spostare il
focus non sul concetto ma sul processo
per esempio tramite esercizi di ricerca
che possano raccordare il contesto
locale dello studente a una scena più
globale ecco in classe lo studente
costruisce il proprio apprendimento
attraverso le domande domande che si
pone e non attraverso il contenuto del
libro di testo e l'insegnante è quindi
in classe non per fornire delle risposte
a per porre le giuste domande affinché
sia lo studente a usare le risorse
disponibili per costruire e apprendere
in modo indipendente
punto 4 insegnante e mentore la scuola
resta perche tutto il giorno spostando
il focus da un apprendimento fine a se
stesso a un percorso di studio più
olistico di socialità e studio e di vita
bilanciando il tempo libero con il tempo
di lezione perché anche il tempo non
formale se iscritto in un piano più
ampio di didattica forma valorizza e
crea
in questa scuola insegnanti sono
continuamente formate a coltivare sogni
e passioni e sono sempre disponibili a
fermarsi rallentare creare legami e
guidare gli studenti verso
l'apprendimento e verso la vita
ecco ecco come trasformiamo il classico
insegnante di scuola superiore in un
insegnante della scuola di domani
sì sono la stessa persona fino al
maglioncino color confetto perché
l'insegnante non sono il problema il
problema è quello che chiediamo loro di
fare e gli strumenti che diamo loro
questa è la scuola di domani una scuola
umana accogliente con cio dal suo perché
e della particolarità di ogni suo membro
insegnante o studente che si sa è una
scuola che nasce al contrario ai
contesti più svantaggiati come risposta
una emergenza ma è anche una scuola
trasferibile che si adatta a
un'emergenza diversa ma altrettanto
urgente
ora come si fa a realizzare tutto questo
primo sì ammette il problema poi è
necessario dare prova alla gente che il
cambiamento è possibile e infine
provocare un azione politica è un
progetto fattibile
lungo però un processo che richiede un
cambiamento collettivo sforzi importanti
se non economici quanto meno di
mentalità
ma se ti dicessi che invece non dobbiamo
affatto aspettare che questa è una
rivoluzione dal basso e che in realtà
sta già accadendo
se ti dicesse che mentre tutto quello
che ho detto finora il vero e con una
menzogna che ho iniziato questo
intervento perché quel ragazzo quello
che avrebbe dovuto finire inscatolare le
merendine non era un mio compagno di
classe noi
la strada di quell'insegnante gli ha
distrutto oppure eccomi qui come ci sono
arrivato qui semplice mentre un intero
sistema mia abili va un'altra insegnante
forse senza neanche rendersene conto da
sola ha fatto la differenza il suo nome
nicoletta e ha deciso di credere in me e
darmi una seconda possibilità e ha
funzionato
è bastato
una sola persona
contro unisse un intero sistema è
bastato ed è questo il punto di tutto il
cambiamento non inizia mai da qualche
ufficio elegante o durante un discorso
preparato
no il cambiamento inizia quando meno te
lo aspetti
è un insegnante ed è uno studente che si
rifiutano di mollare
inizia quando tu
torni a chi per il perche della scuola
tutto inizierà te
la scuola di domani è già qui perché tu
sei già qui
grazie
[Musica]